since you brought up the hijab this is
uh let me get your your reaction to this
one since you mentioned the hijab this
is a popular someone shared this with me
and let's see what you think about this
stays true to her signature style and
reveals why she keeps her body covered
up I never want the world to know
everything about me I mean that's why I
wear big baggy clothes nobody can have
an opinion because they haven't seen
what's underneath you know nobody can be
like oh she's she's slim thick she's not
slim thick she's she got a flat she's
got a fat no one can say any of that
because they don't know I love that
Billie is seriously just breaking the
mold and doing it her own way she wants
people to focus on the fashion and not
her figure how in general would you
describe your style I want to see heads
look up smile has always been something
I care about you're talking about hijab
not totally hit but yeah yeah but I mean
if you think about the meaning of [ __ ] I
like to cover something then yeah I mean
I mean you know it does yeah it just
seems like you know many people that's
why it's so important our education
because it seems like the fitrah the the
natural state of the human being I mean
gets corrupted the environment you know
our surroundings but it's just inside of
us and you just need once Islam comes it
fits like a glove now it gives you that
blueprint you know that's right so you
can see her kind of going toward that
she don't want people to measure her by
her body but by her and tell her that's
right she's doing something a little
above and beyond what everybody's doing
yeah and it's but it's interesting
though of how someone like that is is is
applauded and and praised for it but
yeah how many Muslim women are doing
this everyday and would probably say you
know 70 percent or whatever obviously
it's for a law and it's in following the
commandment like this but what actually
say those same things as well - I'm not
interested in you observing me in a way
that I don't want to be to observe by
you so bill eh
she's like have you ever heard of righty
no no she's like the new thing now okay
so the new Britney Spears yes
Billy Asia I guess she's real popular so
now she's like you just said it's like
she wants to cover up show less wearing
baggy clothes yeah yes pretty much
that's Islam not revealing the shape of
hijab not revealing the shape of your
your body but on top of that having been
just a good human being good moral
character and whatnot who now you said
if as soon as if she would have said
Islam Muslim they shot that exactly well
right then look in the comments section
when Lindsey Lohan or whatever her name
was
yeah took Shahada gradually she's
suffering from mental illness always
other things when she came on I said I'm
covering my body because you know it's
just it's just wow like basically wow
you can be liberated but on our Terms
not Islam yeah exactly you have to be
liberate on our terms
and will determine what liberation looks
like chakra see exactly exactly but the
beautiful thing about though is that
people aren't stupid yes people are not
stupid you know they're mean and and and
you know you can have she comes and says
you can have your own opinions but
you're not entitled to your own facts
you can have your own opinions but have
your own opinions but you know to your
own facts so she's telling you you
didn't mean this fact about me we can
form any opinion we want that fact
remains with her the fact of what
Muslims are doing you can have your
opinion all day the fact will remain the
fact you know you had this whole you
have the the me to movement and we're
not recently we were talking about it
this is this is another point like that
Islam has all these solutions and now
many of these big corporate giants and
whatnot now they're implementing what
you would think like wow this is what
Islam says yeah you know how to interact
with the opposite gender what's right
for the protection of the woman and yeah
and now they're actually implementing
these ends but it's interesting how it
has to run this whole little cycle and
go through being called patriarchal and
all these other things but the end of
the day you're going to come to the same
conclusion right and so but again it's
on our terms yes I think it is and I
think to me that's a rager problem like
I I'm not you know like I don't think I
don't know it's just I was talking to a
student the other day about this idea of
what is it like is the issue like a
theological issue or is the issue one of
like autonomy because think I know in in
the United States of course like this
whole idea about you know freedom and
liberty
and individualism and I think now if one
affirms that there's a god now sudden I
have to be like bound to those rules
like I'm no longer like the top of the
chain like the top of the pyramid so to
speak right there's someone that I have
to and I think that's it that that
becomes a problem for for for for people